Let's go ahead and
create our first application in Flask.
Create a file named project.py
in the same directory
as the database setup.py file.
A minimal Flask application
looks something like this.
Let's take a look at this code
together and see what's going on.
First, I imported this Flask
class from the Flask library.
Next, I create an instance of this class
with the name of the running application
as the argument.
Anytime we run an application in Python,
a special variable called name gets
defined for the application and
all of the imports it uses.
The application run by the Python
interpreter gets a name variable set to
__main__ whereas all the other imported
Python files get a double underscore,
name double underscore variable set to
the actual name of the Python file.
Next, I have this thing that looks like
a function, but starts with an @ symbol.
This is called a decorator in Python.
This decorator essentially wraps our
function inside the app.route function
that Flask has already created.
So if either of these routes
get sent from the browser,
the function that we
define here gets executed.
If this is difficult to follow,
it's okay.
I'll provide a link in the instructor
notes if you're interested in learning
more about decorator functions.
Just know that this
@app.route piece of code
will call the function that
follows it whenever the web server
receives a request with a URL
that matches its argument.
So in this case, if we visit the root
of my site at local host port 5000 or
local host port 5000/hello, this
HelloWorld function will be invoked.
Inside my HelloWorld function,
I return the message I want to
display to the user's browser.
Jumping to the last line of our code,
I use the run function to run
the local server with our application.
The if statement here makes sure
the server only runs if the script is
executed directly from
the Python interpreter, and
not used as an imported module.
So basically, this line of code says,
if you're executing me with
the Python interpreter, then do this.
But if you're importing me into
another Python file don't do this, but
you still have access to
the rest of the code.
By default, the server is only
accessible from the host machine and
not from any other computer.
This is the default
because in debugging mode,
a user of the application can execute
arbitrary Python code on your computer.
Since we're using a vagrant environment
for this course, we must make our server
publicly available by changing the call
of the run method to look like this.
This tells the web server on my vagrant
machine to listen on all public
IP addresses.
Restarting our server each time we
make a modification to our code
can get pretty annoying but
Flask can take care of this for us.
If you enable debug support
the server will reload itself
each time it notices a code change.
It will also provide you a helpful
debugger in the browser if
things go wrong.
I'll save this code as project.py in the
same directory as my restaurant menu db
file and
execute it with the Python interpreter.
Visiting localhost port 500, or
localhost port 5000/hello,
I see the output of my code.
To stop the server, I hit Ctrl+C.
So we see that with much
fewer lines of code,
I executed a similar version of
our Hello World from lesson two.
Notice that with Flask we don't
have to explicitly write out
response codes anymore.
You will soon see that this
is just one of the several
features frameworks take care of
automatically for the developer.